the best time of year is nearly here and
I'm sure all of you watching have a big
long list of what games you want to see
at this year's e3 we are going to be
covering the hottest games and all of
the conference's so make sure you
subscribe so you don't miss anything
until that fateful day though let's
speculate as to what surprises but as de
may have at their conference this year
[Music]
quake champions has spent some time in
the hands of players with his recent run
of beaters so it makes sense that we
will finally see the final fully fleshed
out first-person shooter on stage this
year I spent some time with quake
champions during the beta and while I
had a lot of fun firing quad damaged
rockets and giving folk with rail guns
I'm interested to see how a very
old-school multiplayer shooter does in
the current gaming space hopefully
they'll show off some new weapons new
maps new characters and if I had to
guess some big support for the eSports
scene it looks like two new games will
be getting announced this year as well
and thanks to various leaks and teasers
we have a pretty good idea of what those
games may be bears of course the next
Wolfenstein game and the evil within -
during their showcase last year but
there's the started proceedings with
this old-school style ms-dos command
line screen on said screen they list
older Wolfenstein games along with their
release dates Wolfenstein 3d Wolfenstein
new order old blood followed by the new
Colossus with an unspecified release
date when asked about the e3 tease in an
interview with to let sticks Brian bloom
the voice actor for BJ blaskowitz said
I'll be safe with this answer if you
look at Bethesda XIII 2016 lineup there
was a title hinted at in a very cool way
it sparked a bit of wildfire that's
subtle very simple dose language going
through your titles perhaps we're
working on that as we speak so it seems
like a pretty safe bet that new Colossus
could be the next badass adventure 4bj
all of you burn dr. Blasco heads
shooting stabbing strangling Nazi son
[Music]
[Applause]
now when it comes to the evil within -
earlier this year an eagle-eyed neogaf
user spotted a job description for a
translator and a QA position opening at
tango works the roles to be connected to
psycho break to psycho break being the
japanese name for the evil within tango
works have also said that they wanted
the evil within to be a franchise not
just a single game so the chance to see
more of synergy Mikami's terrifying
machinations seemed pretty high some of
this can be supported by an image that
Pete Hines tweeted on the 20th of April
bear III style theme park of Bethesda
land shows - under construction
attractions and also hints at what else
we could see from them at e3 with quake
and Wolfenstein in mind we may get to
see more of the old-school shooter
reborn the site in the shape of doom a
year after release doom has been
supported with a number of multiplayer
DLCs but many is still waiting to see
more of doom guy's story after that
cliffhanger ending at the end of the
single-player campaign now there's a
chance that Bethesda's conference might
be quite DLC heavy now we've got doom in
mind it may be a little early for them
to be talking about prey DLC but it
seems like a perfect time to talk about
returning to Karnak err
[Music]
this honor to opened up the world past
the confines of dunwall by I'm unsure
whether a dishonor to DLC will go beyond
the seas of Karnataka or explore the
characters similar to the knife of
dunwall DLC I've excited to play through
some of the moments between the two
games see Emily's training or perhaps
explore the shady past of Megan Foster
or even her shady of future at the end
of dishonored - with the incredible
amount of replayability and with the
support of Dishonored two's free updates
it seems like the time is right to dig
out our folding swords and set sail back
to the jewel of the south at the edge of
the world for everyone still exploring
the world of the Elder Scrolls you may
get some more content for Elder Scrolls
online Elder Scrolls online morrowind
releases on June the 6th the week before
e3 so if des de may be keen to share
with their players what's next for their
MMO there's still tons of Tamriel to
explore which means plenty more
potential expansions and worlds for
players to reverse an adventure through
new lands new items perhaps even new
classes with quite a healthy player base
and the support of a huge IP and more
law than you can shake a Khajiit stale
app things could be good for Elder
Scrolls online for a long while to come
and speaking of Elder Scrolls you can
call me optimistic all you like but I'm
hopeful we will get some hints towards
the next full single-player Elder
Scrolls adventure there was a four year
gap between Morrowind oblivion followed
by a five-year gap between oblivion and
Skyrim and has been nearly six years in
Skyrim graced our PCs and consoles so
the timing seems right with Skyrim
coming to the switch and the special
edition being released last year the
environment seems right for the next
Elder Scrolls adventure thousands of
people still play this incredible series
over a number of different systems and
thousands more want to explore those
untouched areas of Tamriel now will we
get to see gameplay or a release date I
doubt it but a nice little tease I'm
hoping so and while we're talking about
our hopes and dreams if we could get
some information on whether or not
obsidian or working on the next Fallout
game I think that would make a lot of
vault dwellers very happy here's hoping
so while Bethesda are keeping their
secrets locked up for e3 this year this
is our list of what we're hopeful for
and what we may see the thirst of
surprises numerous times in the past
with their announcements and I'm sure
they've got something up their sleeve if
there are any Bethesda titles you're
hopeful for make sure you leave them in
the comment section below and if you
want to keep up to date with everything
III 2017 you can subscribe to our
YouTube channel and download the games
for now app for your is or Android
device to keep you in the know when
you're on the go
you
[Music]